je voulais qu'on tente une petite
expérience sur ce plateau ça s'appelle
opération barbichette les armes
attention je te tiens tu le premier qui
rira aura une taupe folie le premier qui
géra aura une [ __ ] est-ce que roch
voisine est prêt en coulisses très bien
attention monsieur marc panis la
variante à peine d'avoir une [ __ ]
attention on n'a pas le choix car c'est
tout le temps on se regarde attention je
compte 1 2 3 4 5 6 seles linda perd du
terrain
et oui c'est toi tu es a pas de calais 1
quel choc est alors c'est un baiser ou
une [ __ ] qu'est ce que vous préférez
c'est toi qui choisis moi qui ai choisi
annoncé vous faire de mon mieux donner
une [ __ ] ou moi je fais un bisou
bah je vais ça fait oui à une [ __ ]
avec mes lèvres merci les gars je trouve
que vous êtes mais bien réussi à bien
réussi cette opération j'ai parlé vous
n'êtes pas réussi mais enfin si vous
voulez il ya eu un grand bruit bien sûr
parce que j'ai un grand moment d'émotion
sur le plateau tout le monde l'a bien
ressenti avec moi alors maintenant on
vous restez avec nous voilà si c'est
beau non non j'en sais rien sur la
prémisse que vous restiez en mode accord
restait à partir de ce répit fiscal